Thank You professor wolf you've
certainly facilitated my contribution
with that very wide-ranging introduction
to the subject let me begin by drawing
attention to the important word or
dignity or rights in the primary
question for today how can we promote
the internal resources of faith
traditions that affirm the dignity or
rights of all human beings with this
word or the question opens up discussion
about whether or not affirmations by
faith traditions of the dignity of human
beings have provided historically and
should provide ethically considered
justifications for universal attribution
to them of equal rights the theoretical
priority of human dignity to human
rights is central to Christian
theological traditions and I will
conjecture to other religious traditions
which this course encompasses and let us
note in passing that this priority has
been recognized by certain United
Nations documents which explicitly
derive rights from the inherent dignity
of the human person all Christian
theologies rooted in the Bible have
offered understandings of human dignity
signifying that the unique determination
worth ontological and moral status of
human beings generically and
individually and these various
understandings have been more or less
hospitable to conceptualizing political
justice in terms of human rights at the
outset we should observe that all
Christian understandings of human
dignity have drawn on the biblical
doctrine of
Margot D the doctrine that humankind was
originally created in the image of God
and that fallen humanity corrupted by
sin has been his being and will be
restored to God's image in Jesus Christ
enjoying on this doctrine Christian
theologians have proposed that the most
adequate understanding of human dignity
must attend to the manifold and ongoing
relations of humankind and of individual
persons to the triune God the Father Son
and Holy Spirit relations initiated and
sustained by God's own creating
sustaining redeeming and sanctifying
action this common Trinitarian ground
however leaves scope for disagreement on
an issue which bears immediately on the
theological assessment of human rights
namely whether the theologian while
regarding divine human relations as
constitutive of the imago Dei and of
human dignity in its fullest meaning can
also entertain a conception of human
dignity in terms of imminent or
self-standing
human faculties qualities or capacities
such as self-consciousness rationality
practical freedom or social relatedness
may the two accounts both claiming
universality be viewed as complementary
or must they be be viewed as
alternatives this issue has obvious
implications for assessing the language
of human rights for rights in the plural
refer to either natural moral or
positive legal powers to have or to do
something attributable to individual or
to collective human subjects and
defensible against all other subjects
thus rights refer to imminent self
standing human qualities or capacities
and moreover they are inextricably
linked to accounts of human dignity into
of such imminent entities the
theological issue presented by human
rights then is whether a language of
natural and political justice that
deflects attention away from the divine
human relationship should be endorsed in
addition to or in lieu of a language
which keeps attention focused on that
relationship I'm not suggesting that
this issue has been and is today the
only issue of theological importance
concerning human dignity and rights
there are important contemporary
discussions about the meaning of human
nature and natural law natural light
about the social dimensions of
individual freedom and moral reasoning
about the objective relational character
of justice and these discussions have
raised weighty objections to the
prevailing liberal democratic theory of
natural and positive rights criticizing
its individualism its volunteerism
ethical irrational ism subjectivism
false egalitarian ism rather I'm
suggesting that the issue of whether and
how a theological exploitation of human
dignity should put God's Trinitarian
relations with his creatures in the
forefront is the controlling theological
issue which sets the range of historical
and contemporary discussions about
dignity and rights in perspective within
the history of Western Christianity
about which alone
I'm modestly competent to speak we can
discern phases in the theoretical and
practical development of positive legal
rights and of natural rights what
precisely these phases are and how they
are related is somewhat disputed
territory among historians theologians
and philosophers and generally speaking
interpretive differences so much to
broader theological and philosophical
positions
my own patchy reading of this history is
shaped by my theological debt to 16th
century English and continental
Reformation thought and practice from
that perspective I am critical of the
eminent conceptuality of human dignity
and subjective rights throughout all
phases of their historical development
but I also wish to discriminate
theoretical and practical articulations
that are more theologically acceptable
with my remaining time therefore let me
briefly sketch a theological account of
human dignity in terms of dynamic divine
human relationships drawing out some
implications for conceptualizing human
rights in this account human dignity
resides pre-eminently in God's manifold
actions by which he makes human beings
in their common existence into finite
images of his infinite perfections by
revealing himself to his human creatures
God communicates his perfections to them
enabling them to participate in his
eternal truth and wisdom his creative
power his bountiful goodness and loving
kindness his righteousness and beauty
God reveals himself to few human beings
in and through the created world which
is the totality of finite creatures in
their ordered relationships and his will
for all human persons is that they come
to know and love themselves their fellow
human beings and the nonhuman creation
has ordered to and by God as imaging his
glory in their distinct modes of being
and action for human beings to know and
to love themselves and their fellow
creatures as manifestations of God's
glory which is their unique dignity is
for them to be continually occupied in a
spiritual worship of
God a worship of reverence adoration
gratitude trust and obedience spiritual
worship generates and gives form not
only to acts of outward worship but to
the whole of the common moral life to
moral freedom and to works of love and
service among fellow human beings human
acts conformed to God's revealed will by
recognizing the specific goodness of all
his creatures but especially of human
beings their unique vocations of
knowledge love and rule over the lower
creatures and the universal and
particular obligations that these impose
in the diverse relationships ordering
their existence within and among
societies God's will revealed in the
created order and immoral acts
conforming to it the right social
relationships preceding these acts and
issuing from them together comprise the
body of natural right of natural justice
worshipful knowledge and practical
obedience are not productions of a self
sufficient human reason and will but of
God's presence too and in the human soul
alumina illuminating the knowing mind
and bringing its spiritual acts to
fruition human beings need God's active
presence not only because of their
natural limitations as psychosomatic
means but because of the sinful
corruption of their minds the deeply
disordered state of their wills and
affections this corruption and disorder
constitutes a wholesale assault on their
dignity precisely because it involves
the redirecting of their affections of
adoration trust and longing away from
God's perfections to an inflated image
of their own so infecting their
knowledge of God of themselves and of
the nonhuman creation
with blind and superstitious fantasies
and depriving them of the moral freedom
to judge and to act rightly it is by
faithful reception of God's saving
revelation in the life death
resurrection and ascension of his
incarnate son that human beings recover
the fullness of their dignity for Jesus
Christ alone has overcome the abyss
between God's communication of his
perfections and humankind's simple
incapacity to respond by bearing the
infirmities of corrupt human nature and
of God's just judgment on human
disobedience to the point of ignominy as
death Jesus manifested simultaneously
the boundlessness of God's forgiving
love for his wayward human creatures and
the perfectly faithful and obedient
human response to God's righteous will
thereby removing the estrangement of
humanity from its maker and breaking its
bondage to sin and death in raising
Jesus from the dead and exalting him to
heavenly glory God decisively recognized
and glorified His image in his human
creature in setting Jesus over the
church to reign to the spirit of
sanctification the father opened the way
for all who are united with Christ
through faith to come into their
inheritance of renewed humanity it is
through the corporate faith and action
of the worshiping church that repentant
sinners participate in an anticipatory
fashion in the human perfections of
their exalted Savior in his freedom and
lordship knowledge and love
righteousness and holiness as fellow
shares in Christ gracious rule through
the Holy Spirit all members of his
spiritual body belong to Christ and to
one another are possessed by Christ and
by one another in
communion of self giving there is no
role in Christ spiritual body for the
work of political or public justice that
is to say the work of rendering coercive
public judgment concerning matters of
communal right and wrong for the
principle purpose of restraining human
wrongdoing and vindicating well-doing
in their ministries to one another and
to those beyond the church's visible
boundaries the faithful stand alongside
their neighbors as equal beneficiaries
of God's saving judgments and not above
their neighbors exercising judgment on
them for the faithful had no judge but
Christ who is both judge and judged
indeed political justice does not
intrinsically and permanently belong to
the perfections of human community
created in and restored to God's image
rather it belongs to the passing age of
sinful humanity and it mirrors both
God's judgment against human evildoing
and his merciful protection of human
community against the destructive forces
of disordered human passions the work of
public justice serves the incomparable
dignity of human beings only by
accepting its limited and remedial
character its dependence on and ordering
to God's creative redeeming and
sanctifying work in human society it
must forego any pretension of affecting
or ensuring the participation of all
persons and communities in the object of
goods and rights of creation and
redemption freely bestowed by the Divine
Spirit and be content with removing the
more damaging external impediments to
such participation
it must renounce the project of defining
social good goods and just relationships
in their royal fullness and be content
to define specific deprivation of good
violations of rights used in the
objective sense harms engine injuries
committed against the individual and the
collective neighbor and degrees of
culpability and to act to correct and
punish such offences its objective must
remain the achievement of peace as
external order the outward harmonization
of wills the visible correction of
wrongdoing and rectification of
injustice the avoidance and termination
of strife and it should not aspire to
encompass the moral regeneration of
offenders and the inward reconciliation
of formerly antagonistic wills let us
now quickly consider some implications
of this account of human dignity natural
right and political justice for
conceptualizing subjective rights it
should be evident that this account does
not require or imply the attribution of
rights to subjects individual or
collective and it is incompatible with
the elaboration of subjective rights
into a groundwork for moral and
political agency action and community
the account places God's active
relations with his human creatures at
the center of the moral and political
universe and attributes Universal and
intrinsic right alone to his self and
will in its act of earthly
manifestations as regards the agency and
action of human beings right refers to
the conformity of their intentions
judgments and actions to the totality of
divinely given goods of persons
communities material and spiritual goods
in their order
and ships within this totality human
beings may encounter one another as
transcending claims as goods that impose
obligations but these obligations are
mediated by their respective
relationships with God earlier versions
of subject of natural light first
propounded by medieval Canon lawyers and
later elaborated by scholastic and neo
Scholastic theologians presented it as a
spiritual faculty power or habit to act
in accordance with objective that to say
natural and divine right or law so for
example the poor man was said to have a
natural right to make use of the surplus
property of the rich to relieve his
extreme need with or without the owner's
permission because he is at de corded
with the divine obligation of sustaining
life very quickly this natural right of
the indigent to act generated a right to
demand or lay claim to the surplus
property of the rich for his use while
the cannabis and scholastics continued
to assert the primacy of objective to
subjective right to their credit they
were also from very early on formulating
a conception of the individual's
ownership of or property in his acts in
other words a conception of freedom as a
property right possessed by the
individual on this proprietary concept
of individual freedom operating within a
progressively attenuated matrix of
natural and divine right were erected
all subsequent contract Aryan theories
of economic social and political society
it took a jurist it
to transpose the paradigm of property
right from the realm of Roman civil and
ecclesiastical law to the realm of
anthropology thereby encouraging a
juridical izing of the world life at its
spiritual root for what is the meaning
purpose theoretical or practical benefit
of a subjective right that is not
defensible in court
it took an equally juristic mind to
suppose that moral obligations entail
subjective rights as their necessary
moral correlate but this is the
prevailing assumption of contemporary
liberalism as we move into an increasing
a juridical and agonistic culture in
which the crusade for egalitarian rights
is hastening the widespread corrosion of
substantive human goods and abetting the
tyrannical aspiration of political
managers to impose the secular
bureaucratic faith and practice on all
social relationships we may well wish to
promote or more theologically open and
less politically circumscribed
conversation among faith about human
dignity and human justice thank you